brooklyn brewery is a power brand with
an enviable problem it's getting to
global in a world that craves proximity
their tonic partner with a local brewer
and let the yeast do the hard work
mixing them mixing the right type of cop
playing around with the right type of
needs of different temperatures gives
you a palette of possibilities to push
on and to paint your beer stock homes
recently opened new Carnegie brewery a
venture between Brooklyn and carlsberg
is located in an old light bulb factory
that was built for disaster the idea was
if this one blows up because of the gas
it will blow explode towards the the
water and not damaging anything up they
understood other industry buildings the
goal to give some of Brooklyn loggers
most loyal fans Sweden is its second
biggest market outside of New York a
beer brewed closer to home you see a
growth that in all locally produced food
stuffs here is the foodstuff and
consumers want to know where their food
is made what they eat what they drink
the brewery wants to become one with the
city this spent grain you can really
smell it we'll go over to the water
treatment plant then get converted into
biogas which will then help fuel the
plan they want to tap the demand for
local products as well as Swedes thirst
for micro beers you move it from brand
to brand but you also move it from
buying basically cheap beers two more
expensive yours so you have a you know
you're a value that grows more than the
volume I wouldn't say that the costs
directly correlate also so you make a
bit more money now for the taste test so
we have a beet salad here not sure we're
going to try that two straight lines of
beer the stock home brewed and then the
Brooklyn brewed my next is the premise
Lux here which I'm going to get it go
ahead and try
and it makes me feel exceedingly witty
it's got some flavor